PRESS CONFERENCE.
PROBABLY SAYING WATCH OUT FOR
PETER DOOCY.
THANK YOU.
JOE BIDEN IS SET TO HOLD THAT
OFFICIAL FIRST PRESS CONFERENCE
ON THURSDAY.
BE A LOT OF PRACTICE THIS WEEK.
SO MAYBE A LOT OF ANSWERS FOR US
ABOUT THE BORDER CRISIS AND I’D
LIKE TO KNOW IF JOE FEELS HE WAS
BLOWN OVER BY THE WIND FRIDAY.
DON’T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
JOE IS LIKELY GOING TO SPEND THE
NEXT SEVERAL DAYS MEMORIZING
PREPARED LINES.
NO PUBLIC EVENTS OVER THE
WEEKEND, NO PUBLIC EVENTS TODAY.
WHILE HIS SCHEDULE HAS YET TO BE
RELEASED, DON’T EXPECT TO SEE
MUCH OF JOE UNTIL THURSDAY, THIS
IS PRACTICE WEEK.
HE SPENDING EVERY WAKING MOMENT
PREPARING FOR THE PRESSER.
HERE WITH PRESS SECRETARY,
KAYLEIGH McENANY .
I DON’T KNOW.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP HELD A RALLY,
THE PRESS WOULD SCREAM AND YELL,
THIS IS A SUPER SPREADER EVENT.
OKAY.
WE SAW GRIFF JENKINS.
I DIDN’T SEE MUCH SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN TIJUANA, MEXICO
WHERE MIGRANTS ARE WAITING FOR
THEIR MOMENT TO CROSS.
I THINK, KAYLEIGH, IF YOU EVER
SAID THAT DONALD TRUMP TRIPPED
WHILE BOARDING AIR FORCE ONE,
BECAUSE THE WIND BLEW HIM OVER,
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU WOULD HAVE
KEPT YOUR JOB AFTER THAT.
>> YEAH, I DON’T THINK SO.
WE ALL REMEMBER RAMPGATE.
THAT WAS THE SLIPPERY RAMP WHERE
IT WAS A HYDROPLANE MOMENT THAT
WAS A WEEK-LONG NEWS CYCLE.
THE TRUE EXPLANATION WAS
UNACCEPTABLE TO THE PRESS AND
THEY RAN WILD WITH HIS
NEUROLOGICAL ISSUES.
IT’S INCREDIBLE WHAT THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE CAN GET AWAY WITH.
I’M HOPEFUL THURSDAY, BUT THE
PRESS NEEDS TO ASK THE HARD
QUESTIONS OF HIM.
I’M NOT SAYING WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE BORDER.
THAT IS NOT A SUFFICIENT
CHECKING OF THE BOX QUESTION.
THEY NEED TO ASK HIM, YOU SAY
YOU BLAME THIS ON TRUMP.
EXPLAIN TO ME SPECIFICALLY HOW
THIS IS TRUMP’S FAULT WHEN HIS
NUMBERS CAME DOWN WHEN HE TOOK
ACTION IN 2019.
THEY HAVE GONE UP AND WEARING
BIDEN T-SHIRTS, FLYING BIDEN
FLAGS AND CITING THEY’RE COMING
HERE BECAUSE OF YOU.
HE NEEDS TO CONFRONTED THAT
DIRECTLY AND THAT SPECIFICALLY.
>> Sean: I’D LIKE TO KNOW IF
IT’S OFFICIAL POSITION IF HE GOT
BLOWN OVER BY THE WIND.
IT’S RIDICULOUS.
NOW WE HAVE VLADIMIR PUTIN
MOCKING HIM.
NOW WE WATCHED WHAT HAPPENED IN
ANCHORAGE ALASKA WHERE CHINA
SPENT 20 MINUTES LECTURING US
ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES.
THERE WASN’T ANY PUSH BACK.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, AN APOLOGY.
MAYBE WE CAN ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS.
A THOUGHT.
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
HE ALSO ASKED -- YOU HEARD PETER
DOOCY SAY AND I SAW THIS, THEY
WOULD NOT CONFIRM WHETHER OR NOT
HE SAW A DOCTOR AFTER OR NOT.
HE SHOULD BE ASKED THAT
QUESTION.
I’LL NEVER FORGET GOING BACK TO
WALTER REED AND QUESTIONS
WHETHER HE HAD A MINI STROKE,
WHICH IS PREPOSTEROUS.
THEY WERE TAKING THAT KIND OF
DEEP DIVE WITH ALL OF THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
YES, THEY NEED TO ASK THAT.
THE DISASTROUS CONFRONTATION
WITH CHINA.
IT WAS BEWILDERING TO WATCH OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE TO APOLOGIZE
TO A STATE THAT IS COMMITTING
GENOCIDE.
BUT WE APOLOGIZE FOR AMERICA
ACROSS THE TABLE FROM CHINA.
IT’S INCREDIBLE.
>> Sean: WHEN THE PRESIDENT GAVE
THE SPEECH AT WEST POINTS, IT
WAS A RAMP AND RAINING.
HE HAD SHOES ON.
THERE’S NO OTHER TIME I CAN
THINK BACK TO WHERE HE WALKED
SLOWLY.
IF I HAVE DRESS SHOES AND IT’S
SLUSH AND ICE AND SNOWY, YOU GET
THAT OH, I GOT THE WRONG SHOES
ON TODAY.
YOU GO SLOWLY.
IT WAS ONE TIME.
AND HE DIDN’T FALL DOWN THREE
TIMES BECAUSE HE WAS SMART